les débats sur l'hydroxyde chloroquine
connaissent une flambée aux états unis
récemment de recherches américaines ont
établi que cet antiviral est efficace
pour traiter la maladie tandis qu'une
étude de l'institut national de la santé
et de la recherche médicale inserm et
une autre menée au brésil conclu qu'elle
n'a aucun effet cela ajoute à la
confusion ambiante dans les débats sur
le sujet aux états unis quoi qu'il en
soit l' agence fédérale compétente la
f10 est à bien révoquer l'autorisation
d'utilisation de la molécule pour le
traitement du kobe 19 le 15 juin dernier
mais au pays de donald trump bien plus
qu'ailleurs le ralliement à la molécule
s'effectue selon la couleur politique
elle est défendue majoritairement par
les anti système et les républicains et
conspué par les démocrates mais l'idéal
de nombreux médecins pensent que c'est
extrêmement bénéfique
d'autres non je pense que c'est devenu
très politique harvey riche professeur
d'épidémiologie à l'université de yale
et partisan de ce traitement estime que
l'hydroxyde chloroquine est au centre
d'une guerre politique c'est un
traitement politique maintenant pas un
traitement médical je pense qu'on se
retrouve à se battre face à une guerre
de propagande contre les faits médicaux
mais en l'occurrence les adversaires de
la molécule controversée pourrait en
dire tout autant car ces derniers jours
la promotion de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
a pris un tour propagandistes dans une
vidéo des joyeux drilles d american
frontline doctors ce petit film devenu
viral le 27 juillet a été visionné des
centaines de millions de fois la vidéo a
même été retweeté par donald trump père
et fils problème son égérie stella
emmanuel à un esprit très fantaisiste
selon elle les etats-unis étaient il ya
peu dirigé par des esprits reptilien mi
humain mi extra terrestres
elle fustige aussi la médecine
contemporaine pour son recours à de
l'adn d'extraterrestres intéressante
hypothèse mais qui n'a pas encore été
validé par ses pairs elle affirmé dans
la vidéo que les mac ne servent à rien
puisque le traitement contre le co lead
existe à base d'hydroquinone rockin
twitter youtube et facebook ont donc
gagné la vidéo à cause de ces deux
fausses informations
il y à la prévention et le remède alors
il ne s'agit pas de parler de masques ou
de confinement mettons nos enseignants
sous hydroxy chloroquine et les médecins
constituant ce groupe très critiquée
pédiatre
gentil ophtalmologue sont avant tout des
militants politiques proches du parti
conservateur tea party exigent depuis
des semaines la fin du confinement et la
réouverture de l'économie américaine ce
battage sur les réseaux sociaux a porté
ses fruits
le vice président mike pence qui
refusait encore il ya peu de porter le
masque lors d'une visite dans un hôpital
aurait reçu le 28 juillet de
représentants de cette association
embarrassante
il lui aurait demandé d'autoriser les
médecins à prescrire de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et pourquoi la molécule cher
au professeur raoul est elle devenue un
casus belli politique aux etats unis
on va séparer les questions de la
campagne de tromper son utilisation de
départ et le débat lui même hors de 30
il y a aussi une méfiance très grande
vers les experts vers le scientifique et
un complexe médiatique qui vendent ces
messages de la peur et préfèrent jouer
sur l'ignorance des gens
la guerre de l'information sur l'idh
roxy chloroquine est donc en plein pic
aux états unis peut-être serait-il temps
de demander à didier raoul s'il n'a pas
aussi dans ses tiroirs un calmant pour
apaiser les esprits américains un peu
échauffés par les guerres de tranchées